so this is a very special day today we
are performing the hot gun the scene
opens up it's my daughter soccer team
and the game is tied and we are looking
to win the game so we perform a hot gun
or our Polynesian culture the haka is
very meaningful playing Hanuman wrote it
and then sent it down to New Zealand so
it was blessed by our elders my biggest
role here was making sure that that
spiritual aspect was embedded into the
people that I was teaching this haka is
very cool and very special and I can't
give the girls enough credit for what
they've done
crazy haka dance this is one of my
favorite moments in the movie
on behalf of our production I'd like to
ask you have in the city of the question
we're losing light let's roll
do you feel like we are honoring the
fast and furious saga with chapter 8
pastor
because all of you who are working hard
and I think it can be in great
yeah yeah yeah well we don't fast thank
baby you think that fans are going to be
really excited by what they're going to
witness
do you feel like this film is going to
have the level of action that our
thoughts fans that grow the custom
do you like what you're saying good
last eight
we're here at the halfway mark and it's
going phenomenally well I have to say it
is going beyond my expectations of abide
to attention to huge
it's really remarkable to see everyone
desire to make something and Radames all
the fans that have been so loyal to the
franchise for so down we're not going to
let up because we know when you got
something special you give it every
ounce of your soul I can't wait for you
guys to see it we're halfway through and
we're smiling for a reason and I think
the quality has got to work they are
thank you for always supporting us in
deliverance
you
premark so here we are in the toy shop
it is one of the most incredible sets
I've ever seen
what I love about this location it's a
great contrast to Cuba it's a lot of
technologically advanced cars where you
have a new bit link the McLaren's the
Maseratis the mercedes-benz the jaguars
and of course one of the most
technologically advanced assault
vehicles on planet earth in one spot it
makes you feel like you're in another
time the only thing that kind of takes
you back which is one of my favorite
cars is the Corvette is that a race boat
you feel like you're in the future here
at the toy shop and I love it
I let him use my garage today for
filming it's not a big deal
you
we add it again sending love from
Iceland let's go
okay boys sir
and now we get to pick up the mess
this is a sequence which we call zombie
cars we've got a big action sequences
taking place here we have seven cars
falling from the parking structure and
each one of them is aiming at a
motorcade area we have to pull these
cars at at an exact speed and we're
doing that using the winch on the crane
each car comes out in succession to land
on the vehicles on the road here
obviously there's no one in them because
you're about to be impaled like three
thousand pound lawn darts we are about
35 to 40 cars in this pileup
that's how we do things are fast
encouraged to do things practical as
long as we do it safe that's a lot of
mine
this action is unlike anything you've
ever seen it's gonna be expected total
carnage let's see the result of this
very very soon
you
I was immediately Huck of making a film
that has that much adrenaline
I play basically the girl who's like
into cars and he's part of a group see
ya
Dominic is a person that has to be tough
it's the only way that he knows how to
take care of the ones he loves
I think every kid at one time or another
it's not about being a cop I get to be a
cop what are you smiling about - Dom was
had you
with this cast it's really really
eclectic in terms of everyone being
different having their own quality to
bring to it it's a cool world I love the
realm I mean I would love to be a part
of it for a long time
want to visit the set of fast eight meet
the cast get a behind-the-scenes look at
the new movie to raise money for the
Paul Walker Foundation the entire cast
is teamed up with amazed to offer you
our biggest our fastest our most
handsome most furious date of your life
will fly you and the guests out to our
sets where you can become the newest
member of the fast family you'll get a
behind-the-scenes look at the creation
of an epic car chase sequence or and and
stuff is your thing I can teach you how
to kick an ass or to just ask Luda if by
kicking ass you mean sucker punch of
friend yeah Michelle isn't asking and
after you meet everyone you'll get a
chance to hop in all the cool cars and
see what it's like to be behind the
wheel I can tell you guys it's my first
time feeling down here and everyone is
extremely hey maybe give me a smoothie
you'll love it they're really nice and
another thing you'll love is free
flights and getting put up in a four
star hotel all on tyrese the extremely
cheap Tyrese yeah yeah yeah all the
penthouse suites and all that all type
of stuff as avid that's nice but the
problem is the carpet and the marble
floors is gonna be slippery as hell with
baby oil thanks to this guy oh yeah of
course he's gonna say that what else is
he gonna say hey if I had a forehead
that big I would say as much as I
possibly could to distract everybody
from looking at my big boy out here it
sleeps eight people comfortably
ah so let's just go to the next person's
part all donations of ten dollars are
more benefit than Paul Walker Foundation
which was created by his daughter meadow
to carry on his legacy protect wildlife
and the oceans of tomorrow and for your
chance to win go to amaze comm slash
fast eight or click the button on tires
why are we talking about my head man
just click it don't click on my head
don't just click it it's a great cord
fly all right that's cool anything for
charity anything from our brother hey
guys uh I got your smoothies thank you
the first global movie to allow
that sure we get to come here and you
can feel the emotion from all of the
levels we couldn't recreate anyway okay
I need photos who are and it to that
table you and seen it in Atlanta happy
to know everybody's excited
you
now what you tell the whole world I see
a sleep webblock yeah I mean well okay
canto quiero
first day with photography me everybody
good
you
you
more more and more less
probably more